George Gamow was a pioneer of the genetic code.
After James Watson and Francis Crick accurately published the structure
of DNA in 1953. Gamow was one of the
leading scientists trying to crack the genetic code, and figure
out how to translate it into protein. Now Gamow
had correctly calculated that three nucleotides was enough to code
for all 20 amino acids, and then some. But the
real question was whether or not the genetic code was
overlapping or not. In other words, Gamow favored a
model where a sequence of letters in RNA would
be read in sets of three. But after reading
the first triplet, the second triplet began with the second
letter of the first triplet. And so on. Now
this was referred to as the overlapping model because each
codon overlapped with another. An alternative model suggested that
there was no overlap and one triplet was read right
after another triplet and so on. So of these models, which
one do you think would be the most efficient for information storage?